well
it's happening
Chloe Cole a detransitioned 18 year old
woman announced the first official
lawsuit in the United States against the
hospital and Affiliated Medical Group
that facilitated her medical transition
as a minor we knew only time would tell
what effect the societal push for
transgenderism would have on the
children involved in this this egregious
experiment there is now a rise in
detransitioners former transgender
people who now identify with their
biology it's reported that Chloe's
family sought after the medical
treatment from those institutions she
then received irreversible chemical and
surgical sex change interventions
between ages 13 and 16. the current
lawsuit alleges that the defendants
coerced Chloe by concealing less
invasive treatments and by lying to her
about her condition Chloe said once I
announced my intention to seek Justice I
have not stopped receiving call after
call email after email of parents and
patients who have been harmed by these
same practices some of them even were
butchered in the same building I was to
me this is the case of the biblical
proverb when I was a child I thought as
a child but when I became an adult I put
away childish things Charles lamandry
believes that Chloe was a victim of
ideological and profit-driven medical
abuse that included indoctrination into
transgender ideology the off-label use
of puberty blocking drugs and cross-sex
hormones and a double mastectomy surgery
that resulted in excruciating pain and
suffering permanent disfigurement loss
of enjoyment of life and extreme
emotional distress this is a very sad
situation and in an effort to protect
our children God says in Isaiah chapter
54 13 all your children shall be taught
by the Lord and great shall be the Peace
of your children so do you think Chloe
has a case on the one hand it can be
argued that Chloe isn't denying that she
had gender confusion as a child actually
she's the one who asked for this
treatment and technically the law
restricts therapists from advising
against one's perceived reality when it
comes to their sexuality on the other
hand parents and and medical
institutions should treat children as
children and not inflict irreversible
and self-destructive procedures based on
a child's feeling that will most likely
change in the near future
well what do you think let's talk about
in the comments below
hey thanks for watching this video
making this kind of content is only
possible because of our patrons who
donate through patreon or through our
website so if you enjoy little life
Studios content please consider making a
monetary contribution today
[Music]